jetpack für feuerwehr 100 millionen
gerätschaft kommt endlich zum einsatz
und ketten im fahrzeug für den privaten
gebrauch das sind drei der fünf themen
in den krieg zum top five news jetzt 100
millionen euro maschine kommt endlich
zum einsatz im marburger ionenstrahl
therapiezentrum kurz mrt sollte im jahr
2012 eigentlich eine partikeltherapie
anlage in betrieb genommen werden
der 100 millionen euro schwere
kostenpunkt machte damals allerdings
sprichwörtlich einen strich durch die
rechnung jetzt da jahre später wird sie
endlich in betrieb genommen zitat das
ist ein wichtiges signal an die vielen
schwerkranken menschen die sehr große
hoffnung in eine faszinierende technik
setzen so boris rhein der
wirtschaftsminister von hessen eine
partikeltherapie wird in der
krebsbekämpfung bei schwer
beziehungsweise tief gelegenen tumoren
eingesetzt
mit hilfe einer dafür geeigneten anlagen
können gezielt die tief gelegenen
unkompliziert befallen gewebe beschossen
werden unter kompliziert befallen
versteht man beispielsweise ein tumor in
der nähe von essenziellen nervensystem
helfen könnte man mit der
partikeltherapie anlage schon bald
vielen menschen zitat wir denken dass
wir in zwei drei jahren 700 patienten
jährlich behandeln können so der
geschäftsführer des ion strahlt
therapiezentrums jürgen debus
indien möchte im kommenden monat ein 150
milliarden euro projekt starten worum
geht es es geht um eine verbindung bzw
eine vernetzung von wasserquellen mit
wasserquellen ist so gut wie alles
gemeint vom fluss bis hin zu neuen
wasserreserven grund des gewaltigen
bauvorhabens die regionale
wasserknappheit bzw
der regionale wasser überschuss zwei
absolut gegensätzliche gründe aber so
sieht es in indien aus man könnte sagen
dass in indien zwei wasserverfügbarkeit
zonen existieren in den nördlichen und
westlichen regionen kommt es zeitweise
zu einem starken wasser über angebot in
den südlichen und östlichen gebieten
jedoch herrscht das komplette gegenteil
im zuge des projekts sollen rund 30.000
wasser saurer und rund 30 kanäle gebaut
werden also im zuge des projekts nicht
alles im dezember das neue wassernetz
könnte bis zu 105 74 274 millionen liter
wasser dorthin leiten wo das wasser
wirklich gebraucht wird auf einer
wasserleitungsbau stelle welch eine
überleitung sind in new york grabstätten
aus den jahren um 1800 entdeckt worden
in einer tiefe von gerade mal
dreieinhalb metern stieß man im erdreich
des washington square park auf ganze
zwei stück untersuchen darf sie nun
erstmal niemand die totenruhe verbietet
das und was nun
aktuell müssen sich die archäologen vor
ort mit bildmaterial zufrieden geben
auf den bildern sind jede menge sage zu
sehen und einige davon sind sogar
geöffnet noch mysteriöser ist die
tatsache dass die menschlichen überreste
der zuerst entdeckten grabstätte
teilweise sehr seltsam dort liegen wo du
da schon vor dem jetzigen funde die
totenruhe gestört und warum kommen wir
zu einer nachricht die weniger mit 2 1
aber mit wahrgewordener fiction zu tun
hat 1 720 ps ketten fahrzeug für den
privaten gebrauch der traum dass kleiner
junge nicht davon mal einen quad oder in
einem kettenfahrzeug durch den dreck zu
rasen fast jeder von uns und für die
etwas älteren kinder gibt es jetzt die
möglichkeit sich diesen traum zu
erfüllen die fiktion könnte mit dem
tinga bald realität werden wie das
gefährt aussieht und was es kann seht
ihr in einem kurzen ausschnitt aus dem
werbefilm des herstellers den link zum
kompletten video findet ihr natürlich
unten und in der video beschreibung bei
den quellen und wenn er jetzt auf die
produktplatzierung kennzeichnung wartet
die kommt nicht es ist nämlich keine
wir finden das gefährt und die das
bildmaterial super interessant wer jetzt
sehen werdet
dem jetpack zum brandherd dubais
feuerwehrmänner sollen zukünftig mit dem
martin jetpack ausgerüstet werden
dass martin jetpack ist ein 250.000
dollar teures gerät das einen
halbstündigen flug in bis zu 1000
höhenmeter erlaubt mitnehmen kann man
auf seinem flug dann auch so einiges
rund 120 kilogramm würden kein problem
darstellen jetzt noch mal langsam ein
jetpack für feuerwehrmänner ja
tatsächlich das ist in dubai wohl das
erste mal dass sowas eingesetzt wird und
es hat einen klaren grund die
wolkenkratzer samt feuerwehrausrüstung
rund 700 höhenmeter zurückzulegen
das ist wohl alles andere als ein
spaziergang und genau da kommen die
jetpacks zum einsatz sie sollen keine
lösch apparaturen darstellen oder als le
speck agieren 1
sie sollen hauptsächlich als
transportmittel dienen gute sache
eigentlich oder oder wie seht ihr das
macht das überhaupt sinn
oder bringt dass er schwierigkeiten mit
sich und würdet ihr euch ein
kettenfahrzeug wie den finger zu legen
lasst es uns in den kommentaren darüber
diskutieren über ein abo würde ich mich
natürlich sehr freuen
das ist natürlich kostenlos und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran und
schaut das nächste video